.
♪♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FIRST THE GOOD NEWS, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ABOUT TO
SUFFER A HUMILIATING REPUDIATION
IN NEXT WEEK'S MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
IT SEEMS THE DEMOCRATS WILL LOSE
BOTH HOUSES OF CONGRESS.
THAT'S JUST THE BEGINNING OF
THEIR PAIN.
POLLS SUGGEST THAT EVEN PLACES
THAT SUPPORTED JOE BIDEN BY A
WIDE MARGIN IN 2020 ARE ABOUT TO
SWING DRAMATICALLY AGAINST HIM
AND HIS PARTY.
A WEEK FROM TODAY, NEW YORK OF
ALL PLACES, COULD HAVE A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR.
THE LAST TIME THERE WAS AN
ELECTION IN NEW YORK, BIDEN WON
THE STATE BY 23 POINTS.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS WHAT
POLITICAL SCIENTISTS REFER TO AS
A REALIGNMENT.
THERE'S NO MYSTERY AS TO WHY
IT'S HAPPENING.
DEMOCRATS FAILED CONCLUSIVELY.
NO GROUP IN AMERICAN HISTORY HAS
DONE A WORST JOB RUNNING THIS
COUNTRY THAN THE NATIONAL
THAN THE LIBERALS INCHARGE.
THEY'RE CORRUPT AND INCOMPETENT.
IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS, NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT TO SAY, THEY HAVE
RUN THIS COUNTRY INTO THE
GROUND, WRECKING OUR ECONOMY,
DESECRATING OUR MILITARY, AND
OPENING THE BORDERS TO THE
UNITED STATES TO MORE THAN
5 MILLION LAWBREAKERS.
THE DESTRUCTION THEY HAVE
BROUGHT IS SO PROFOUND IT'S HARD
TO DESCRIBE.
OF COURSE THERE'S CANADIENS FORS
FOR THAT.
HOW CAN THIS PARTY STAY IN
POWER?
TONIGHT BIDEN TRAVELED ACROSS TO
UNION STATION, BUILT BY TEDDY
ROOSEVELT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO, ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL BUILDINGS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
UNDER JOE BIDEN IT'S BECOME A
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT, TOO FILTHY
AND TOO DANGEROUS FOR STARBUCKS.
STANDING AT THIS MONUMENT TO HIS
OWN FAILURES, BIDEN PROCEEDED TO
DO WHAT HE NOW SO COMMONLY DOES,
BARK AT THE REST OF US FOR OUR
MORAL FAILURES, THE GUY WHO
SHOWERED WITH HIS DAUGHTER IS
TELLING YOU YOU'RE A BAD PERSON.
TONIGHT'S TOPIC, DEMOCRACY.
HERE'S A TASTE OF IT.
>> MAGA ELEMENT OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, A MINORITY OF
THAT PARTY, ITS DRIVING FORCE,
IS TRYING TO SUCCEED WHERE THEY
FAILED IN 2020.
TO SUPPRESS THE RIGHT OF VOTERS
AND SUBVERT THE ELECTORAL SYSTEM
ITSELF.
>> Tucker: THAT'S VERY WEIRD, IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
HERE WE ARE LESS THAN A WEEK
BEFORE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
EXPECTED TO SUFFER OVERWHELMING
LOSSES IN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS,
AND YOU HAVE THE LEADER PATH
FEATER, JOE BIDEN, COMMANDING
NOT TO COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
ELECTION RESULTS.
WHY IS THAT?
WELL, LET'S SEE.
HERE'S JOE BIDEN TELLING YOU
THAT THANKS TO THE CHANGES, THE
MANY CHANGES, DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE TO OUR SYSTEM OF VOTER, ALL
OF WHICH MAKE VOTER FRAUD EASIER
TO COMMIT, WE MAY NOT KNOW THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTIONS FOR A
FEW DAYS.
DON'T BE ALARMED.
EVERYTHING IS COMPLETELY ON THE
LEVEL.
WHATEVER YOU DO, DO NOT ASK
QUESTIONS OR ELSE YOU'RE A
CRIMINAL.
WATCH.
>> WE WANT AMERICANS TO VOTE.
WE WANT EVERY AMERICAN'S VOICE
TO BE HEARD.
NOW WE HAVE TO MOVE THE PROCESS
FORWARD.
WE KNOW THAT MORE AND MORE
BALLOTS ARE CAST IN EARLY VOTING
OR BY MAIL IN AMERICA.
WE KNOW THAT MANY STATES DON'T
START COUNTING THOSE BALLOTS
TILL AFTER THE POLLS CLOSE ON
NOVEMBER 8th.
THAT MEANS IN SOME CASES WE
WON'T KNOW THE WINNER OF THE
ELECTION FOR A FEW DAYS AFTER
THE ELECTION.
TAKES TIME TO COUNT LEGITIMATE
BALLOTS FROM A LEGAL AND ORDERLY
MANNER.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN IMPORTANT FOR
CITIZENS IN A DEMOCRACY TO BE
INFORMED AND ENGAGED.
NOW IT'S IMPORTANT FOR CITIZENS
TO BE PATIENT AS WELL.
THAT'S HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
WE'RE A WEEK FROM THE ELECTION.
SIX DAYS.
BIDEN COULD HAVE GIVEN, WOULD
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES, HAVE
GIVEN A SPEECH ABOUT HIS
POLICIES, HOW THEY'VE MADE YOUR
LIFE BETTER, TRY TO CONVINCE YOU
THIS COUNTRY IS IN BETTER SHAPE
THAN IT LOOKS.
HE DID THAT.
HE COULD HAVE, IN OTHER WORDS,
MADE A PITCH FOR YOUR VOTE BASED
ON WHAT HE'S DONE.
THAT'S WHAT POLITICIANS DO IN
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACIES.
THEY TRY TO CONVINCE YOU TO
SUPPORT THEM ON THE BASIS OF
WHAT THEY'VE DONE FOR YOU.
THAT'S DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S NOT AT ALL WHAT JOE BIDEN
JUST DID.
INSTEAD BIDEN COMMANDED YOU TO
ACCEPT THE ELECTION RESULTS
WHENEVER THEY ARRIVE, NO MATTER
WHAT THEY MAY BE.
IT WAS BIZARRE.
IT DID NOT INSPIRE CONFIDENCE.
YOU WOULD HATE TO THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS A
VERSION OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
TONIGHT IN BRAZIL.
ACCORDING TO OFFICIAL TALLIES, A
CONVICTED CRIMINALIST BEAT THE
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT BY A NARROW
MARGIN THIS WEEKEND, AND YET
MILLIONS OF BRAZILIANS,
MILLIONS, DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
THERE ARE PROTESTS ALL OVER
BRAZIL RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE SEEING SOME ON YOUR
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER ALL THE BALLOTS HAD BEEN
COUNTED.
WHY SO MANY WERE THROWN OUT.
MILLIONS.
WHETHER ELECTION LAWS WERE
VIOLATED IN THE PROCESS.
SO WE CAN'T RENDER JUDGMENT ON
THOSE QUESTIONS, BUT IF YOU CARE
ABOUT DEMOCRACY, THINK THE
PROCESS IS ESSENTIAL, THEN YOU
WOULD LOOK INTO THOSE
ALLEGATIONS.
ANYTHING LESS IS NOT A
DEMOCRACY.
YOU'RE NO LONGER TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS ELECTION IN
BRAZIL.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED, BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
WANT YOU TO.
THAT'S TRUE.
YOUTUBE, WHICH HAS FUNCTIONED
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS, AS AN
ARM OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
HAS ANNOUNCED IT'S CENSORING ANY
POSTS IN BRAZIL THAT QUESTION
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
BRAZIL'S COURTS HAVE ALSO
REJECTED ANY INQUIRY INTO THE
ELECTION.
A JUDGE HAS ORDERED SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO REMOVE SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS THAT QUESTIONS THE
OUTCOME.
OVERWHELMING CENSORSHIP IN A,
QUOTE, DEMOCRACY PRESENTS PEOPLE
FROM ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THE, QUOTE, DEMOCRACY FUNCTIONS.
SO WHY SHOULD YOU CARE ABOUT
THIS?
BRAZIL, IT'S A LONG WAY AWAY.
WELL, TWO REASONS.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE RESULT OF
THIS ELECTION WILL DETERMINE THE
EXTENT OF CHINA'S INFLUENCE IN
THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE.
LEFT WING GOVERNMENTS LOYAL TO
CHINA, OUTSIDE OUR SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE, WILL CONTROL ALL OF
SOUTH AMERICA.
BRAZIL WAS THE LAST HOLDOUT,
ALSO THE BIGGEST AND MOST
SIGNIFICANT COUNTRY IN SOUTH
AMERICA.
IT'S OUR HEMISPHERE.
IT MATTERS.
THE SECOND REASON YOU SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION, THE CRACKDOWN ON FREE
7'IN THE WAKE OF BRAZIL'S
CONTESTED ELECTION IS A RESULT
OF POLICIES FROM OUR COUNTRY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN INTERFERING IN THE
ELECTIONS IN BRAZIL, PERIOD.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALREADY ANNOUNCED THAT BOLSONARO
LOST AND THREATENED CONSEQUENCES
IF HE TRIES TO
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTION.
REALLY?
THIS IS AN ELECTION THAT'S
CONTESTED, THE DEMONSTRATIONS IN
THE STREET PROVE THAT.
THAT'S NOT BEEN AUDITED, THAT
APPARENTLY CANNOT BE AUDITED,
AND YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
HOW DOES THAT RESTORE YOUR FAITH
IN INSTITUTIONS?
NO.
ONLY ONE THING RESTORES YOUR
FAITH IN INSTITUTIONS, AND
THAT'S TRANSPARENCY.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE HIDING THINGS IT
MAKES YOU THINK MAYBE THEY HAVE
REASON TO.
OF COURSE.
WHEN GOVERNMENTS HIDE THINGS,
YOU COULD BE DEAD CERTAIN
THEY'RE LYING, PERIOD.
BUT FROM AN AMERICAN
PERSPECTIVE, THE QUESTION IS WHY
WAS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
INTERFERING IN A FOREIGN
ELECTION.
THESE ARE DEFENDERS OF
DEMOCRACY, WHO BELIEVE IN FREE
AND FAIR ELECTIONS.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE MEDDLING IN
OTHER PEOPLE'S ELECTIONS, BUT
THEY ARE.
A LOT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO, THE WOMAN AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, DRIVING
OUR WAR AGAINST RUSSIA, WAS
CAUGHT ON TAPE ADMITTING SHE
ENGINEERED A COUP IN UKRAINE,
AND SHE WAS PROMOTED.
AGAIN, SHE'S STILL AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IN BRAZIL.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HATED
THE LAST PRESIDENT IN BRAZIL FOR
POLITICAL REASONS, IDEOLOGICAL
REASONS, REASONS THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT WAS IN
AMERICA'S BEST INTEREST, BUT THE
SILLY LIBERALISM THAT DETERMINES
THEIR WORLD VIEW.
WE TRAVELED THERE, AND WARNED
TOP OFFICIALS THAT BOLSONARO
COULD NOT CONTEST THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
WAIT A SECOND.
WHY WOULD THE CIA BE IN BRAZIL
LECTURING THEM ABOUT THEIR
ELECTIONS?
ISN'T THAT INTERFERING IN AN
ELECTION?
OH, YES IT IS.
THEN MONTHS AFTER THAT VISIT,
BRAZIL'S COURT-ORDERED THE
INDEFINITE DETENTION OF SEVERAL
BOLSONARO SUPPORTERS.
WHAT THEY DID THEY DO WRONG?
ATTACKED BRAZIL'S INSTITUTIONS
IN THEIR PRIVATE COMMUNICATIONS,
UNDERMINED CONFIDENCE IN
ELECTION INTEGRITY, SO THEY HAD
TO GO TO PRISON.
IT'S SHOCKING.
THE MOST SHOCKING PART IS NOT
SIMPLY THERE'S CORRUPTION IN A
LATIN AMERICAN COUNTRY.
THAT'S PAR.
THE SHOCKING PART IS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
REINFORCING IT, TRYING TO DO THE
SAME THING HERE.
WE SAW A PREVIEW OF THIS IN THE
UNITED STATES AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN BRAZIL NOW
IS AN ESCALATION.
ONCE AGAIN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ENDORSES IT, HAS
A HAND IN IT.
WITHIN HOURS OF A CONTESTED
ELECTION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN BANNED
FROM TALKING ABOUT IT.
STREET VIOLENCE IS BREAKING OUT
NATURALLY.
SO-CALLED ELECTION DENIERS ARE
BEING KILLED.
WHY WOULD YOU IMAGINE ANY OTHER
OUTCOME IN THE ABSENCE OF
TRANSPARENCY WHAT FILLS THE
VOID?
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
IF YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BELIEVE
THE TRUTH, TELL THEM THE TRUTH.
STOP HIDING THINGS.
THAT'S NOT A FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY.
IN A FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY,
YOU'RE NOT SIMPLY ALLOWED TO
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT ELECTIONS,
YOU'RE ENCOURAGED TO.
YOU'RE ENCOURAGED TO, BECAUSE
IT'S YOUR GOVERNMENT.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
ELECTION DENYING IN A FREE
SOCIETY.
IT'S CALLED FREE SPEECH.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO SAY IT IF YOU
THINK IT, PERIOD.
AND YET OUR MEDIA, WHICH EXISTS
TO DEFEND FREE SPEECH, IS DOING
ITS BEST, DAY AFTER DAY, TO SHUT
IT DOWN.
HOW DARE YOU RAISE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT NEXT WEEK'S MIDTERMS.
WHY ARE THEY TELLING YOU THAT?
IT'S OMINOUS.
HERE'S MSNBC MAKING IT EXPLICIT,
THAT IF YOU VOTE FOR A
REPUBLICAN IN PENNSYLVANIA, DOUG
MASTRIANO, YOU'RE DESTROYING
DEMOCRACY THROUGH VOTING.
WATCH THIS.
>> OF THOSE 299 ELECTION DENYING
CANDIDATES, THAT'S THEM ON THE
SCREEN, 173 OF THEM ARE FAVORED
TO WIN THEIR RACE THIS YEAR
WHILE 52 OTHERS ARE IN
COMPETITIVE RACES WHERE THEY
STILL HAVE A CHANCE OF WINNING.
THEIR COLLECTIVE VICTORY COULD
HAVE CATASTROPHIC CONSEQUENCES
FOR AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
IT'S POSSIBLE IN A COUPLE.
YEARS, AS A RESULT OF THE 2024
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS ARE BEING
CERTIFIED, PEOPLE LIKE LAKE AND
MASTRIANO, OVER 150 MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, WHO SPENT THE LAST TWO
YEARS, SEWING SEEDS OF DOUBT
ABOUT THE LEGITIMACY OF JOE
BIDEN'S VICTORY, IT'S LIKELY
THEY'LL BE IN POSITIONS OF POWER
THAT HAVE AN OUTSIZED INFLUENCE
ON THE OUTCOME OF FUTURE
ELECTIONS AND WHAT THEY MIGHT DO
WITH THAT POWER IS WHAT VOTERS
NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT TODAY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IF PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE LAST
ELECTION, OR JANUARY 6th, OR
WHAT HAPPENED AT NANCY PELOSI'S
HOUSE IN SAN FRANCISCO LAST
FRIDAY, THERE'S A REALLY SIMPLE
WAY TO PUT THOSE CONCERNS TO
REST, TO STOP THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
THAT'S PRODUCE THE EVIDENCE.
SHOW US THE FACTS.
IF PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT VOTE
TOTALS IN A SPECIFIC STATE FROM
2020, FIRST OF ALL, THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO HAVE THE PARTY IN
CHARGE PROVE THAT -- PROVE THAT
ELECTION WAS FAIR.
BUT MOREOVER, THEY HAVE A DUTY
TO ASK, BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY YOU
HAVE A FREE AND FAIR SYSTEM IS
IF EVERYBODY IS FREE TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT AND DEMAND
REAL ANSWERS.
IF YOU'RE COMING UP WITH SOME
SORT OF CRAZY THEORY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AT NANCY PELOSI'S HOUSE
LAST NIGHT, INSTEAD OF YELLING
AT YOU, CALLING YOU NAMES, A
CONSPIRACY, ALEX JONES, PRODUCE
THE POLICE BODY CAM.
WHY IS THAT SO HARD?
IF YOU THINK SOMETHING WEIRD WAS
GOING ON JANUARY 6th, OKAY,
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT, MAYBE IT'S
THE FAULT OF PEOPLE HIDING
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF VIDEO
EVIDENCE FROM JANUARY 6th.
WHY HAVEN'T THEY RELEASED THAT?
THE ONUS IS THEM, NOT THE REST
OF US.
WE'RE NOT THE CRAZY PEOPLE.